let me ask sort of
um an advice question to uh
the young folks you've explored a lot of
fascinating ideas in your life
you built a startup worked on physics
worked in computer science what advice
would you give to young people today
in high school maybe early college about
life about career about science and
mathematics
i remember like i read like i remember
reading
that um poncario was once asked by
um a french journal about his advice for
young people
and what was his teaching philosophy and
he said that
like one of the most important things
that parents should teach their kids is
how to be enthusiastic um in regards to
like the mysteries of the world
and that he said like striking that
balance was actually one of the most
important things between like
in education you know you want to have
your kids be enthusiastic about the
mysteries of the world but you also
don't want to traumatize them like if
you really force them into something
and i think like especially
if you're young i think you you should
be curious
and i think you should ex explore that
curiosity to the fullest
to the point where you even become
almost as an expert on that topic
and now and you might start with
something that it's small like you might
start with
you know you're interested in numbers
and how to factor numbers into primes
and then all of a sudden you go and and
you're
like lost in number theory and you
discover cryptography and then all of a
sudden you're buying bitcoin
and and i think you should do these um
you should really try to fulfill this
curiosity and you should live in a
society that
allows you to fulfill this curiosity
which is also important
and i think you should do these not to
get to some sort of status or fame or
money
but i think this is the way this
iterative process
i think this is the way to find
happiness and
and i think this is also allows you to
find the meaning for your life
i think it's all about like being
curious and being able to fulfill that
curiosity and that path
to fulfilling that your curiosity yeah
the the the start small let the fire
build is kind of
interesting way to think about it and
you never know where you're gonna end up
it's it's like for instance from us it's
just a really good example we started
like
by doing this as an internal like thing
that we did
with in the company and then we started
putting out there and now a lot of
people follow it and know about it
and so um and you still don't know where
fermara's library is going to end up
actually
true exactly so um yeah i think that
would be my
piece of advice with very limited
experience of course but
yeah yeah i agree i agree
uh i mean is there something in from
particular
journal from the computer science versus
physics perspective
uh do do you regret not doing physics do
you regret not doing computer science
which one is the the wiser the better
human being this is messy versus ronaldo
those are very i i don't know if you
would agree but they're kind of
different disciplines true yeah
very much so um i actually actually uh
i was i had that question in my mind i i
took
physics classes uh as an undergrad or
like besides what i had to take and um
it's definitely something that i
considered at some point um
and and that that i
i i do feel like later in life that
might be
something that i'm not sure if regret is
is the right word but it's it's kind of
something that i can imagine in an
alternative
universe what would have happened if i
if i've gone into physics
um i try to think that like well it
depends on
what your path ends up being but that
it's it's not super important right like
exactly what you decide to
major on like i think there's there's um
i think tim urban like the blogger had a
good visualization of this where it's
like
you know like he he has a picture where
you have all sorts of paths that he
could pursue in your life and then
maybe you're in the middle of it and so
there's maybe some paths that are not
accessible to you but like the the tree
that is still in front of you
gives you a lot of optionality and so um
there's two lessons to learn from that
like we have a huge number of options
now
and probably you're just one to reflect
like to try to derive wisdom from the
one little path you've taken so far
maybe flawed because there's all these
other paths you could have taken
yeah so it's like uh so one it's
inspiring that you can take any path now
and two
it's like you you the path you've taken
so far is just one of many possible ones
but it does seem that like physics and
computer science both
open a lot of doors in a lot of
different doors
it's very interesting it is yeah i i
like in this case like and
especially in in our case because i
could see the difference i studied i
i did i went to college in europe and uh
went to college here in the us so i
could see the differences like in the
european system is
um more rigid in the sense that when you
decide to study physics you don't have a
lot especially in the early years you
don't have a lot of
um you can't choose to take like a class
from like computer science course or
something like that you don't have a lot
of freedom to explore in that sense in
university as opposed to here in the us
where you have more freedom
and i think um i think that's important
i think that's what
constitutes you know a good kind of
educational system
is one that gravitates towards the
interests of
a student as as you progress but i think
in order for you to do that you need to
explore different areas and i i felt
like if i had a chance to take
say more computer science class when i
was in college i would have probably
have taken those classes but um yeah but
i ended up like focusing maybe too
too much in physics and i think here at
least
my perception is that you can explore
more more
fields but there is a kind of it's funny
but physics can be difficult so i don't
see too many computer science people
than ex
exploring it to physics it's only like
the one
not the one but one of the beneficial
things of physics it feels like it
uh what was it rutherford that said like
like basically that physics is the hard
thing and everything is easy
uh so like there's a certain sense once
you've figured out some basic
like physics that it's not that you need
the tools of physics to understand
the other disciplines is that you're
empowered by having done difficult [ __ ]
i mean the ultimate i think is probably
mathematics there yeah
true so maybe just doing difficult
things
and proving to yourself that you can do
difficult things whatever those are
that's not positive i believe not
positive yeah
and i think like i i before i started a
company i had
like i worked in the financial sector
for a bit
and like i think having a physics
background i was i felt i was not
afraid of like learning like finance
things and i think like when you come
from those backgrounds you are
generally not afraid of stepping into
other fields and learning about those
because
um yeah i feel they've learned a lot of
difficult things and um yeah
that's an added benefit i believe
this was an incredible conversation luis
joao
we started with uh who do we start with
feynman ended up with messi and ronaldo
so this is like the perfect conversation
it's really an honor that you guys would
waste all this time with me today
it's it was really fun thanks thank you
so much for having us yeah thank you so
much
you